when it came to the extra fee he just
couldn't let it be anyway sir paul
mccartney the former lead singer of an
oasis cover band
is urging starbucks to ditch its
surcharge on plant-based milk options
even though they cost more to produce
and are an abomination before god in a
letter he penned with peta using vegan
paper and cruelty free inc mccartney
writes i understand that in other
countries like uk and india there is the
same charge for both types of milk and i
would like to politely request that you
consider this policy also in starbucks
usa i sincerely hope that for the future
of the planet and animal welfare you are
able to implement this policy end quote
now when he's not ripping off the
monkeys mccartney has had long history
of promoting a vegan lifestyle and peta
claims cow's milk generates three times
more greenhouse gas emissions and uses
nine times more land than plant-based
options well you could say the same
thing about human milk but it just
tastes better
though if we're paying a little less for
plant milk i bet i can think of one guy
who's all for it i ate a plant face
centered life
i eat a plant-based scented life either
plants based scented life i eat a
plant-based scented life
some people want to call me vegan vegans
eat oreos and they drink coca-cola i
don't
i eat a plant-based scented life ah it's
gonna be a great mayor alright do
coca-cola yeah
yeah by the way um you know this is a
very important topic pierce especially
when you're dealing with tea i think we
have us uh a little uh thing about how
you take your tea do we
here's the problem with the way
americans make tea they make it too weak
or they over stew it but they never get
it right the recipe the crucial thing
it's scientific fact get the milk in
first make it stew for four minutes not
five not three stir after two minutes
have a bag per cup and one on top
we didn't start a revolution to drink
that crap
which is why we drink american tea it's
like british tea with better abs here's
how it's made
first the tea leaves are loaded onto a
fighter jet and shot into the sun
next they go into bags and get signed up
for an illegal fight club where they
learn that violence solves all problems
then skydivers deliver the tea for
steeping directly into an active volcano
they don't survive but the tea comes out
great next we had milk from cows born
inside monster trucks and heat it with a
flame thrower and nachos there's nachos
in there for some reason so say goodbye
to earl grey and hello to earl red white
and blue it's american tea
[Music]
that was amazing no wonder americans
don't drink tea yes exactly we don't
understand it uh is this something that
sir paul should be worried about you
know well first of all let me preface it
by saying that i'm i'm loathe to
criticize support because i am a massive
beatles junkie but secondly i introduced
him to head the mills ah you're the one
which ended up costing him 60 million
pounds in the divorce so i owe him one
um but there's something utterly
insufferable about self-righteous vegans
and the i think the particular thing
that exercises me about them is they all
love drinking almond milk for example
now let me know about the process of
making almonds
almonds involves the extermination of
billions of bees in california over a
five six week period every year uh it's
the same with various other vegan
products they're not as squeaky clean as
i like to make us out to be bees are the
little guys of this debate and
i like to stand up for the little guys
the bees right the bees vegans never
care about the bloody bees they never
care and they should right they should
care about the bees they're gonna drink
your almond milk and try and take the
high moral ground with me with my real
milk from proper cows proper goats right
cows aren't killed by the milk types
look at your own backyard first and look
after the bees yes you know isn't it
ironic that the beetles prefer plants
yeah well it's also ironic whenever you
hear a billionaire complain about the
price of an extra bucket for at a
starbucks that you know his assistant to
his assistant is getting for him yes you
know but let's not even get into that
there everything's about gender and
proper
okay there's no such thing as almond
milk almonds do not have nipples
therefore they cannot produce milk
correct it's ground up almonds and it's
not just the bees it's the worms the
beetles the grubs rats lizards all the
little things so there's tons and tons
of different species of animal snakes
that are wiped out by these yes by these
i didn't know yeah and yet yet they get
mad because they kill a cow for beef
exactly right saying like you need to
make it the problem is i guess the cow's
cuter so that's the that's the that's
the no it's just big enough yeah bigger
it's easy to point out we
consciousness to size so we assume that
bees don't think haley but they have
their own little thoughts it's usually
uh of course they do yes like jim acosta
he has his own thoughts as well
and he's barely conscious yes there's
that exactly um unlike piers i'm not a
beatles fan i like country music
why is it that seat
everybody hates the beatles
was that they were overrated it's like
oh changing music wasn't enough for you
so if you're personally not a fan that's
one thing his was just just an
unnecessary smear he crossed some
seriously yeah yeah
you know he might not never be back on
the show
although he has been said i'm sorry
kaley no i mean i was just going to say
there's nothing more elitist than a
celebrity pinning an open letter saying
like i need free non-plant-based milk i
don't even know what that is all i can
say is the boys of leonard skynyrd they
would not have been this way so i i
stand by my not a beatles fan although
they're all not because they'd like all
of them are dead they are except a few
except a few yes yes yes and i don't
laugh at that i'm a huge skinnered fan
but of course yes i slow dance to free
bird often alone
um by choice would you like to add to
this beetle mania
sure i mean so
obviously yes i'm a huge beatles fan i
don't know the guy pierce uh he doesn't
uh he's a good guy no he doesn't know i
exist and never will but that doesn't
stop me um
never has
but i kind of love it because
it kind of proves how full of starbucks
is in a way right because they have this
whole section on their website and like
signs in their stores about
environmental responsibility and it's
like cool then take some yeah you know
they could afford to make it all the
same price but it just proves that
they're just you know capitalists but
lying about it and there there should be
a tax for being an annoying vegan yeah
you can be an annoying vegan but we're
gonna tax you for it that's it but if
you were a billionaire being a vegan
wouldn't even be hard
but he's not good as much fun as he used
to because i introduced him to heather
mills but to be fair to him he might be
down to his last 500 mil yes uh give him
some credit you know it's also an attack
on women too right the bees thing bees
are 95 females
correct that out there so it's another
weather attack on women it's just not
that you know as much about the bee
thing as i do sir david attenborough
should have been my father yes
yes all right and on that note hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else